le coeur du problème en matière de pma
qu'elles soient ou non étant dus à des
couples homosexuels ou à des femmes
seules
c'est que pour qu'il puisse y avoir une
pma il faut et bien fait compter des
embryons
il faut ensuite pour faire la simulation
faire un tri d'embryons ce qui relève
d'une politique de type eugéniste d'une
part et d'autre part eh bien ça signifie
que tous les embryons qui ne seront pas
implantés
eh bien ils vont être soit détruits soit
congelés donc en fait on est dans une
progression de loi les unes par rapport
aux autres où on dérégule de plus en
plus la recherche scientifique sur les
embryons et où on ne prend pas en
considération le fait que la vie humaine
ça n'est pas une chose qui est au
service des autres vies humaines une vie
humaine en soi
et bien c'est quelque chose qui a de la
valeur qui ne peut pas être traitée et
bien comme une comme une chose que je
rencontre aujourd'hui c'est des couples
qui sont en grande souffrance parce
qu'ils n'ont pas d'enfants et
aujourd'hui si on refuse toutes les
évolutions de la pma et si on les avait
refusé tout il n'y aurait pas de pma et
il n'y aurait donc pas en gros 3 % des
naissances en france qui surviendrait
puisque 3 % des naissances aujourd'hui
en france sont issus d'assistance
médicale à la procréation et ce seraient
des milliers des milliers de personnes
qui seraient encore en souffrance faute
d'avoir un enfant la l'infertilité est
une maladie on sens premier du terme
elle est défini comme tel par
l'organisation mondiale de la santé donc
on se doit de pouvoir comme toute autre
maladie essayer d'y remédier aujourd'hui
ce sont des techniques qui font appel à
des technologies sur des gamètes pour
essayer de constituer des embryons les
embryons sont constitués au laboratoire
et il ne faut pas croire qu'on fasse du
tri aujourd'hui dans les embryons parce
que ce n'est absolument pas vrai soyons
progressiste la question aujourd'hui à
l'est de faut-il ouvrir la pma oui il
faut l'ouvrir parce qu'elle répond à des
problématiques sociétales et à des
demandes sociétales qui me paraissent
parfaitement légitime
parce qu'il ya des enfants qui
effectivement s est bien il ya tous ceux
qui sont qui ne peuvent pas naître et
qui sont éliminés je suis au regret de
dire qu'aujourd'hui on n'y a aucune
contrainte juridique mais il y a une
pression sociale énorme pour qu'une
femme ne puisse pas mener une grossesse
si jamais un de ses enfants
si jamais l'enfant qu'elle porte est
bien est atteint d'une maladie génétique
et en particulier effectivement la
trisomie 21 ça a été évoqué autrement
dit de la contrainte sociale à
l'obligation juridique il n'y a qu'un
pas et je reconnais que je fais partie
de ceux qui la craignent
effectivement quel est le comment dire
là la beauté de la vie et bien c'est le
fait qu'il y est un risque
en aucun cas on est dans de la sélection
de caisse qui va donner un enfant normal
pas normal aujourd'hui on est dans l'est
dans la sélection un palace élections
ont d'ailleurs dans la dans leurs
placements des embryons qui ont le des
chances de donner une grossesse
ceux qui ne sont pas utilisés sont pas
des embryons qui aurait donné des
malformations parce qu'encore une fois
on ne le sait pas
ce sont des embryons qui n'aurait pas
donné bourse s donc c'est pour éviter à
des coûts d'avoir à subir le désagrément
d'avoir un échec de leurs tentatives
concon mais ceux qui ont le plus de
chances d'avoir un succès il n'y a en
rien de sélection pour savoir si il va y
avoir malformations pall mall formation
si c'est un garçon si c'est une fille
s'il va avoir les yeux bleus ou pas les
yeux bleus tout ça c'est c'est de la
fantasmatique et l'objectif c'est
d'avoir encore une fois ce sont des lois
de bioéthique donc des lois
donc il va y avoir un cadre nous on
demande à ce que le cadre soit modifié à
la faveur des progrès médicaux à la
faveur des des avancées sociétales
mais nous demandons en aucun cas qu'il
n'y ait pas de cadre et bien sûr que non
personne et moi le premier je ne suis
absolument pas favorable à l'ogc nice
c'est quelque chose qui m'effraie au
plus haut point
une question aussi importante que la
bioéthique la procréation la filiation
le mariage ce sont un certain nombre de
questions dont il faut être certain que
la société en a bien mesuré les enjeux
et que par conséquent ce sont des
questions qui sont toujours discutable
qui sont sans cesse susceptibles d'être
remises sur le tapis n'y a pas d'effet
clic et qui voudrait que eh bien parce
qu'une loi a été votée dans le temps
passer eh bien ça ne serait pas à
nouveau de nouveaux discutable donc je
pense que si on arrive à poser les
enjeux les positions de manière sereine
et sans anathème et bien un débat peut
parfaitement avoir lieu y compris sur
des choses qui ont été autorisés par le
passé et qui pourrait redevenir illégal
à l'avenir je ne suis pas très inquiet
aujourd'hui et même si le sénat c'est cv
montré contre les évolutions et
notamment celle de d'ouvrir la pma aux
femmes célibataires aux femmes en couple
étonnamment finalement par rapport à ce
qui s'était passé en première lecture
c'était était relativement inattendue je
pense que ça va être corrigé par la
commission mixte et finalement entérinée
par l'assemblée nationale qui elle n'a
finalement jamais bougé sur ses
positions et il est fort à parier mais
indépendamment de la 2de ce débat-là
finalement c'est une promesse de
campagne des bagnoles macron une
majorité à l'assemblée où le savez comme
moi et quand même et quand même vers la
république en marge
donc il est quand même très très très
probable au vu des deux premières
lectures de l'assemblée
on en arrive a finalement acté c'est en
tout cas ces deux mesures là